jessica is in California hi Jessica
welcome to the show how can I help
hi Davison honor to speak with you you
too what's up I'm calling I'm calling
because we are house poor and I've been
listening to you for a couple months now
and I just really want to make a good
long-term plan to get out of this okay
what do you what's your house payment
it's twenty eight hundred a month twenty
seven eighty and we take home about
fifty four hundred a month right now
okay yeah you are
is there a change in your income coming
soon a big change well we just bought
this house because you know the mortgage
broker told us we could afford it and is
there a big change in your income coming
soon if I get a job yes if you get a job
what would that know to your income it
would add significantly maybe about a
thousand to two thousand a month more
okay which still doesn't get us there
two thousand a month would not change
this nut situation would it well it's
hard to know because we're in California
and so rents as high as well let's
mortgage is not here okay well you're in
an expensive part of California for sure
and California is some super expensive
real estate by and large agreed with
that but that doesn't mean you get a
pass on math you can't make it like
you're sitting right now and having a
thousand or two thousand a month you
still can't make it so you bought a
house you can't afford right there's no
question about that unless you have a
situation where your household incomes
getting ready to double you bought a
house you you can't afford and I'm not
hearing that yet in this conversation so
and you can't just say well rents are
expensive that means you just can't live
in the area you're in with the income
you have that's what it means I mean if
your rents are just as high and you
cannot find anything that's around 1/4
of your take-home pay that means that
the expense of the area it's an area
that is too expensive to live in for
that income and that's not that's not a
shame but there's no there's no way you
get to just decide to live somewhere you
can't afford I mean you know if you if
you make fifty thousand dollars a year
you cannot live on the Upper East Side
of Manhattan
you cannot afford right right to expect
so many family my husband and I we have
three kids and we decided to move out
here because the schools were good both
of our kids need to be in a good school
they have some learning disabilities and
we left a cheap house and bought an
expensive house and we're just you know
our homes are spending a little bit we
started a debt snowball or we're really
trying to make an effort out of it you
can't breathe though mathematically
you're smuggling you're smothered yeah
yeah I appreciate that you want to take
care of your kids you may have to move
to a different end of the country where
you can get schools I don't know for in
an affordable area I don't know I don't
know but I do know that you're not going
to win sitting there you're gonna be
bankrupt within five years if you stay
right where you're at
you cannot exist with children
especially children with special needs
in a family where you're spending twenty
eight hundred dollars in your take-home
pay is five thousand you just can't do
that and it's not going to work it's
gonna catch up with you something's
gonna happen something's gonna break
something's gonna blow up and it's just
a matter of time before this falls in on
you and so you know you're gonna have to
admit that you made a mistake and you're
gonna have to reverse the mistake and
sell the house and you're going to look
for an area that can serve your purposes
that you can afford to live in and take
care of your children with needs and
there are areas of the country that'll
do that it may not be right there where
you are right now it might involve a job
change it might involve a
major move a location change several
states over I don't know
but you you just can't do what you're
doing it won't work you can't I can't
make it work for you there's and I can't
and I'm not going to tell you to try so
don't do it don't do it
hope that helps thanks for the call